okay so the next question that I had
was do you feel like standards should go
up or down as we get older for men and
for women
go around for men and for women yeah
I think
standards go up for men
as we get older
because every I say everybody a lot of
people know that um we have to we have
to earn our value
so when we're 17 18 19 20 nobody cares
about us unless you've got game and you
just you've got it to give up nobody
cares
um it's always women on a pedestal and
we're trying to chase them
and as you get older
the tables turn
it does turn
um so Things become you're more together
right I've got my house got my car got
this I'm stable I you know I've come
into my own I'm going to the gym I'm
working out my lifestyle is good so
we're earning that
um
but we were saying that even getting to
35
um once you get to 35 that's going the
other way you're going down in value
um my options are getting greater as I
get older they're not deteriorating when
I was 19 17 18.
nobody cared about my life
simple as that nobody cared as I got
older attention more attention more
attention as you get older as you get
wiser if you've got a lot more to offer
because I've got you know experience in
this that and for
for women that is valuable
um because that's what women are looking
for we're not running around like 21
year olds because
that's you know we've done it
um so yeah I think is is very clear that
as we get older men
our value goes up
and as females get older their value I'm
sorry to say it goes down can I just add
to that before you move on to the next
person one thing that I learned was
women
are born with value yes and so when you
hit 18
you find that you're not allowed to go
clubbing you're allowed you people give
you the kind of pretty girl privilege
access to things
they say that what a man on a boat has
worked his whole life to be on that boat
yeah he's had to go through the
financial trouble tax evasion all of
that to be on that boat
a beautiful woman age 20 could be on
that same boat and they're in the exact
same place with him yeah they end up in
the same place and and just to go one
stage deeper I've got two sons and a
daughter so when my daughter are you
smiling you've been on a boat
I've been invited to zero boats yeah
sorry I ain't got a boat yet anyway
except my dad's boat but I've got I've
got two sons and a daughter so
from very young my daughter anywhere you
go oh she's so beautiful in the shops
people on the street it doesn't happen
with the boys do you know what I mean it
doesn't happen that's how I really
recognize that oh she's cute she's this
men women children alike and that's
where their value from that my
daughter's value from when she was born
my son's yeah he's all right exactly so
women are born with value men have to
create their value most definitely and
so that's the premise that men will only
become value as they get older if
they work on themselves and actually do
something if they develop if they
develop if you don't just being older
isn't enough you have to have essential
qualities
yeah
um okay I feel like in terms of men you
guys are on the right track like in
terms of like men aren't
born with value like I feel like over
time the more like knowledge you have
the more experience you have you kind of
like you get to a point where you're
able to have options compared to like
when you are younger
um in terms of women
I do understand what you're saying in
terms of
um
you know women having
um value from the beginning you know
people coming up um women saying oh it's
so pretty having pretty privilege that's
definitely a thing I feel like
um I feel like over time again
um I feel like women still do have
experience like you do gain experience
over time
um I'm not gonna come and lie and say
that there's not a point where
you kind of your value becomes Less in
men's eyes
just know that we don't value experience
though yeah we don't value experience
females do it value experience we don't
okay that's another thing as well but um
I wouldn't say that
well we I wouldn't say it's less I
wouldn't say women become less value
I'll just say in you guys's eyes that
well so not personal value we're talking
about like sexual Marketplace value so
like your value in the sexual
Marketplace yeah then I'd say that then
then that's kind of true then if that's
the case
um
I would say that yeah if you're talking
in terms of the sexual marketing place
then obviously it's the case because no
one would go to a man necessarily and
say he looks pretty but I would say in
terms of
in terms of
value again I would say for both men and
women
I'd say for men definitely obviously as
they age
up to a certain point their value
increases I would agree with what he
said in terms of the men with women
I would say that the pretty privileged
thing is stops our point so there has to
be something more than the pretty
privilege
which is why I disagree with the
leftover print
yeah
and so she just totally confused me
because if a man
when the woman is Young
she's more valuable
and the older she gets sexually about a
look start going in she starts drooping
everything's just going south
whereas a man
you know you start hearing about Silver
Fox you know I mean men can keep it out
forever do you know I mean women just
hang everywhere the men are just always
going to be there what's up
Leonardo DiCaprio
I don't know
teach us when you get old sexy
gray-haired man that's you know you look
at most of the eligible men out there
you know and they're old they've got
their body together look at their gray
hair George Clooney you know and they
look good
now look at him at his age and look at
the women at that age now if we're
saying that women lose their value as
they get older and Men gain more value
as they get older that's what you're
going to end up with women at 35 on
their own because they're losing value
so you can't say yeah I agree with men
gain value women lose value and then
disagree against the fact that when you
hit 35 your body's mash up for most of
you and then the men could still carry
on developing they can still carry on
that is why no old man wants to sleep
with an old woman no old man wants to
sleep with an old woman all the old men
they want young women because the men
have still got it and the women have
lost it
he's like 25 too old
because he can't he like not every guy
can do that but when you when you leave
men that have the most opportunity just
like to sleep with women they always
pick a young woman
typically except Jeff Bezos I don't know
what you're doing man so if you're 35
the only way you can look good date a 70
year old you're always going to look
better than the 70 year old yeah sorry I
just think it's it's good that she made
the distinction that it's the sexual
Market I think that's where the
difference is if you're basing it just
on sex then clearly then that's that's
where the woman's value is talk to a man
to a man